قالت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان الخارجيه
الامريكيه استدعت سفيره اسرائيل في واشنطن
مايك هرتسوك بعد اقرار الكنيست قانونا
يلغي اخلاء اربع مستوطنات في شمال الضفه
الغربيه واضافت الاذاعه ان نائبه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
وينديت لسفير الاسرائيلي عن القلق واشنطن
من هذا الاجراء الذي وصفته بالاستفزازيه
واوضحت المسؤوله الامريكيه ان من شان هذه
الخطوه الاسرائيليه ان تدفع الى مزيد من
التوتر خلال شهر رمضان واعياد الفصح
اليهودي والمسيحي يذكر ان الكنيست
الاسرائيلي صدق بالقراءتين الثانيه
والثالثه على الغاء بنود في قانون فك
الارتباط في اربع مستوطنات شمال الضفه
الغربيه وذلك بعد 18 عاما من اقراره ما
يتيح للمستوطنين دخول هذه المستوطنات مره
اخرى واعاده الاقامه فيها المتابعه ينضم
الينا الامن القدس مراسل الجزيره احمد
هزيم ما قبل قليل احمد لم تكن هناك اي
ردود فعل على المستوى الرسمي في اسرائيل
تتعلق باستدعاء السفير الاسرائيلي في
واشنطن هل من جديد في هذا الملف
ليس اسرائيليا ازدهار هناك بيان للخارجيه
الامريكيه عن هذا اللقاء ذكرتي بعضا من
مقتطفاته الذي عبرت فيه ويندي شيرمان عن
استياء الولايات المتحده وقلقها البالغ من
هذا القانون الذي يشرع مره اخرى
للمستوطنين
الاستيطان في هذه المستوطنات الاربع شمال
الضفه الغربيه او حتى بناء مزيد من البؤر
الاسترطانيه هناك وهذا القلق او هذا الغضب
الامريكي انجاز التعبير هو زياده في منسوب
الامتعاض في لدى المسؤولين في واشنطن من
حكومه وحلفائه وشركائه في الائتلاف
الحكومي من احزاب اليمين الديني المتطرف
هنا في اسرائيل هذا الامتعاض بدا منذ
بدايه بدايه منذ تصريحات وزير الماليه
سمارتش عندما طالب او نادى بمحو قريه
حواره
وبدانا الان نلمس ابتعاض اكبر لدى الجانب
الامريكي من تصرفات الح الاسرائيليه وسعها
الى تقويض اي مسار لحل الدولتين كما تقول
واشنطن وكما تقول الخارجيه الامريكيه في
على اكثر من الصعيد هناك فعلا غضب شديد
لدى الولايات المتحده من هذه الاجراءات
التي تقوض المخرجات القمم التي ترعاها
الولايات المتحده وراعتها الولايات
المتحده سواء تلك في العقبه او حتى قمه
شرم الشيخ ومسعى واشنطن للتهدئه قبيل حلول
شهر رمضان المبارك هنا في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هذه الاجراءات التي تقوم بها
اسرائيل هي بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
تقويض لهذه الجهود الولايات المتحده
ازدهار ليست فقط ممتعظه وغاضبه من هذه
الاجراءات التي تخص الفلسطينيين وتقوم بها
اسرائيل او يقوم بهذا الائتلاف الحكومي
عبر سن التشريعات في الكنيست انما حتى
انها
قلقه جدا وعبرت على اكثر من صعيد من
الاجراءات البينيه بين الاسرائيليين
انفسهم بين المعارضه وبين حزب الليكول